because Mercury is way too hot Venus is
horrendously hot and 90 atmospheres
pressure and sulfuric acid rain it melts
lead on the surface right so you're not
going there and the rest of them are
made of gas so you're not going there
either so so Mars is the only place
beyond Earth that we could feasibly ever
go a planet
[Music]
so Brown we're doing this episode of
minutes with very different from
anything we've done before we put a
survey out to the audience ask them to
send in all the questions they want to
ask you
what is the one fact about the universe
that blows your mind the most
there are a lot of things about the
universe that that I find it almost
impossible to imagine well actually
impossible to imagine one just the size
and scale of it I mean in the piece of
the universe we can see
there are something like roughly two
trillion galaxies I think we haven't
counted them all but that's a an
estimate based on surveys of the local
Universe 2 trillion 2 000 billion
galaxies and each Galaxy is let's say
around the size of the Milky Way some
are bigger some are smaller but the
Milky Way has 400 billion stars in it it
takes light over a hundred thousand
years to cross a Galaxy and there are
two trillion of them in the piece of the
universe we can see and we're very sure
that that piece that we can see is a
small bit of what may be an infinite
universe beyond we don't know actually
and I always say you know don't get
worried about that because nobody can
picture it it is impossible to visualize
the Scale of the Universe and so that's
the first thing I could I could then
list a lot of moral things but we'll
stop there for now but just the size and
scale of it I think is beyond
imagination
there's been a lot of references to the
Multiverse and parallel universe in
popular culture in Italy do you think
that something like this is a
possibility
so there are lots of multiverses
actually
um in physics one of them is called the
inflationary Multiverse which is we have
a theory of um essentially what happened
before the Big Bang right you have to be
careful with the language so if you
define the Big Bang really carefully as
the time when the universe was very hot
and very dense and as I said you can't
argue with that because we can see it
because we can look out into this guy
our best theory of how the universe got
into that state
is that there was a time before that and
it's called inflation so the idea is the
universe was
he was there in a sense cold and empty
and expanded extremely fast and that
expansion slowed down and stopped and
the energy that was driving that
expansion got dumped into space heated
it up and made all the particles out of
which we're made and that's what we call
the big Bank
so that's textbook it's a textbook
Theory cold inflation it made
predictions some of which had been
tested some incredible predictions
actually about the way that galaxies are
distributed across the sky because
they're not just random if you look at
the galaxies they're in sort of flows
and rivers of galaxies that cross the
sky in a pattern called The Cosmic web
and inflation predicted that before it
was seen actually so it's an astonishing
idea and that theory has a kind of an
extension called Eternal inflation which
is that the inflation essentially goes
on forever
and it just stops in little patches so
you imagine this this straight the
fabric of the universe Face Time Stretch
stretch stretch and then it slows down
and stops and little patches and each
one of those patches is basically a big
bang and a universe of which ours is one
so you end up with this sort of picture
of a an infinite fractal Universe of of
basically an infinite number of big
bangs and that's called the inflationary
Multiverse
and that that there's something it
answers some neat questions that because
it if you say why is our universe the
way that it is what why are the laws of
nature such that life can exist for
example
um well the answer might be that all
possible combinations of all the laws of
nature exist in the inflationary
Multiverse so then it's not surprising
there are universes that permits things
like us to exist because every possible
Universe exists in the inflationary
Multiverse and that that's a a
well-supported theory it's a theory so
this is not the same as saying there was
a big bang which we know this is kind of
what's the theory it's a guess basically
but it is a theory that in its simplest
form has made predictions that have
subsequently been verified and we could
go on then as the the so-called many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics which is more kind of Marvel
film kind of Multiverse where um so
quantum mechanics is
it's a probabilistic theories imagine a
Quantum coin I call it and the quantum
coin can be it doesn't have to be heads
or tails it can be heads and tails it
can be mixed up can be both heads and
tails at the same time you may have
heard of Schrodinger's cat which is a
cat in a box and it's both alive and
dead until you observe it or interact
with it in some way and then you find
out which one it is but before you
looked at it or before you interacted
with it it was both
you've talked about the number of
galaxies does any of this ever make you
feel insignificant yeah I mean so um I
say sometimes in my live shows there's
only it's kind of a joke right so I'm
not insulting philosophers here but I
say there's only one interesting
question in philosophy and I don't
really mean it but I think it sounds
funny and so the interesting question is
what does it mean to live a finite
fragile life in an infinite Eternal
universe so that's not that funny right
it's a good question what does it mean
to live a finite fragile life in an
infinite Eternal universe and um I think
the answer
is that
sort of paradoxically whilst we are
definitely physically insignificant I've
just said you know that the Earth is one
star around one that the Earth is one
planet around one star amongst 400
billion stars in one Galaxy amongst two
trillion galaxies in a small patch of
the universe right so we're definitely
small and you can't argue with that
we're just effects of dust but if you
think about what we are
so everybody me and you everybody we're
we're just collections of atoms right
some of them are as old as time pretty
much and some of them were the other
ones everything else other than the
hydrogen in our bodies was made in Stars
right so so we all cooked over billions
of years and we're in this pattern that
can think
so suddenly there's the great Carl Sagan
said you have a means by which the
universe understands and explores itself
which is us
and that sounds unlikely when you put it
like that that you can have a few things
that were cooked in the hearts of stars
you stick them together in the pattern
and suddenly he has some ideas and
starts writing music and an art and
things that's that's quite difficult to
comprehend right but that what that
happened here we know that because we're
sat here having a conversation and so
the question then becomes well on how
many other worlds did that happen
and that's where I think the value can
come in
because it's a reasonable guess and it's
just a guess right but it's reasonable
you can make the argument that there
aren't any other worlds where this
happened certainly in our galaxy
so it could be this planet
notwithstanding its physical
insignificance it's the only place where
anything thinks right for millions of
light years in every direction I'm
suddenly therefore you end up
considering this planet as being the
most valuable place in the local
Universe notwithstanding the fact that
it's small and that idea it's not just a
complete random guess by the way we've
had a bit of a look where astronomers
have pointed radio telescopes up at the
stars for a while 50 years or more now
and heard nothing we've seen no evidence
of any civilizations out there beyond
Earth and that's a surprise there's a
reasonably plausible explanation for
that which is biology which is that if
you look at the history of life on Earth
then you see that life began pretty much
as soon as it could here on Earth we
have evidence there was life 3.8 billion
years ago something like that and the
Earth four and a half billion years old
so pretty much pretty quick in
geological time you get life
but then if you talk about Advanced like
complex life multicellular life then
there's no evidence at all
Beyond uh back Beyond a billion years
actually really in the fossil record 650
million years ago or something you start
seeing the first evidence of complex
creatures so that means that on he on
this planet it took over three billion
years to go from single cell life to
anything more complex than a single cell
and then another half a billion years or
so to go from the multicellular things
to a civilization so it's three and a
half to four billion years it's a third
of the age of the universe that is a
really long time if you say that's an
unbroken chain of life on a little piece
of rock in a violent universe and that
chain was not cut for four billion years
in order to get us and that might be a
big ask right we live in a really
violent Universe you look at the Milky
Way and you look at the Arc of stars
across the sky 400 billion Suns although
all they will be up there at best is
slime
it's just slime nothing right and I
think that's a reasonable guess that's
my that's where I start from I mean I
wouldn't be surprised if that's wrong
then you go okay good well fine that but
at the moment
it looks like there isn't anything else
other than slime we haven't even
discovered Slime by the way yet we're
still in the position where we've not
seen anything not even a single cell on
mars or you know the moons of Jupiter or
somewhere like that so at the moment we
are alone
as far as we can tell
do you have a favorite planet star or
Galaxy out there
the favorite planet well um it's it's a
cliche right but I saw I I actually
asked this is a name John I asked Jeff
Bezos that question so there's a name
and he said correctly Earth
Earth is the best and that's true so so
because of everything I've just said
right I just said it's the only place
where meaning exists potentially in a
galaxy of 400 billion Suns so that would
be your favorite planet as a result of
that but beyond that it's in the solar
system so let's go to to Elon Musk as
mentioned the other rocket rocket
engineer
um so he wants to go to Mars
um might well get to Mars
um that's the only other planet you
could go to actually in our solar system
because Mercury is way too hot Venus is
horrendously hot and 90 atmospheres
pressure and sulfuric acid rain it melts
lead on the surface right so you're not
going there and there's rest of them are
made of gas so you're not going there
either so so Mars is the only place
beyond Earth that we could feasibly ever
go a planet we could imagine perhaps
going to some of the moons of Jupiter
and Saturn in the far future that's much
more difficult
what would happen if we traveled into a
black hole so the old answer of what
happens if you jump into a black hole is
you go to the end of time that's this
pure Einstein right you just so you get
spaghettified on your way to the end of
time which means you get stretched
infinitely actually and then squashed
and you'd say well you get dissociated
into a strain of atoms and then
everything goes to the end of time
now as of 2019 I would say uh we think
that if you think of yourself as
information
so if you think of a let's say I think
very 2022 right let's say you burn a
book very fashionable today's current
political climate so burn a book and and
collect everything that comes out of the
book all the ashes and all the gas and
everything then in principle you can
reconstruct the book They're not in
practice right but you can imagine if
you collect every single thing and
measure it in principle you can
reconstruct the book information is
conserved in all of physics which means
that so basically if you can measure
everything perfectly you can you can
predict what happened in the past and
what's going to happen in the future
it's called determinism then right so
the the old picture of black holes and
Stephen Hawking believed this for a long
time and that's about it actually is
that they seem like they destroy
information you can just kind of see it
goes to the end of time right it's gone
but and then they evaporate away
and it seemed that though there was no
way even if you gathered all the Hawking
radiation that had come off for
trillions of years there's no way you
could reconstruct or went in so
therefore he jumped into a black hole
you'd be erased from the universe
well that breaks pretty much every law
of physics right things don't erase
information they scramble it up make it
difficult to read but they don't destroy
it but now we think actually no even
black holes don't destroy information so
it turns out that now we think and this
is very 2022 papers right if you jumped
into a black hole then we do think that
if a super being in the far future could
collect every bit of Hawking radiation
that was event that came off the black
hole for trillions and trillions of
years and stick it into a giant quantum
computer then they Could reconstruct
everything that fell in so actually in
some sense you come out Stephen Hawking
had a bet with John preskell about this
so and it was I I can't remember I think
it was the 90s when he conceded the bet
it might have been late 80s but it so he
had a bet and the BET was the black
Stevens calculation initially from the
70s said that black holes destroy
information
so he thought that was true for a long
time and he had a bet with John Prescott
it turned out that the BET was a set of
encyclopedias so whoever lost the vet
would have to give the other one a set
of encyclopedias and uh John Prescott
asked for baseball encyclopedias and uh
because of some work by someone called
maldicino actually ultimately Stephen
said no no they don't destroy
information the information comes out
it's conserved so he conceded the event
and gave John preskull the encyclopedias
he said what I should have done is I
should have burnt the encyclopedias and
giving him the ashes because all the
information still right so yeah
you described earlier on you described
the universe as a dangerous piece of
violent place what is the most likely
way that the world could end
well so the the world the way that the
world the Earth will end ultimately is
is a cinder right it's because what's
going to happen is that the sun in about
starting in a few billion years time
actually but it's going to start growing
it's going to be it'll grow as it gets
older and it'll swell up it probably
won't engulf the Earth but it'll get
close
you know the Earth will probably drift
out because it's sort of lose some Mass
so it probably but it'll toast it
basically so the Earth will end up
toasted as a cinder probably still
orbiting the remains of the sun which
shall be what's called a white dwarf
star which is just something that
basically Fades away
so that's what's going to happen in
about five billion years I'm laughing
because it's you know well that's what's
going to happen so um so that's that's
how our world ends as a crisp basically
it's Cinder
um if you even by the end of the world
you mean the end of civilization then um
long before that we will had to escape
because it will become the the
conditions on the planet will not be
will not support complex life like us
it'll be too hot
um but uh you know the the possibility
is that we discussed we could destroy
ourselves which is um
you know it would be given that it's
quite possible that there is nowhere
else
um in a galaxy then as we said before
that would be a really silly thing to do
so I think it's more likely
we might not have to wait for the sun to
do it because we might do it through our
own stupidity
and then can you talk a little bit about
the dart that's been high there for an
asteroid protection how what is that
mechanism well yeah so it sounds like
science fiction doesn't it you say well
you know we've all seen Hollywood films
where asteroids come and don't look up
right brilliant film I think
um where an asteroid comes in we don't
even believe it so you see it and people
don't even believe that things come in
that's real right that you know we know
the dinosaurs other than the birds were
wiped out by a big asteroid impact 65
million years ago we know that
so um so it occasionally big pieces of
rock hit the earth and occasionally
those big pieces of rock are big enough
to cause Mass Devastation that easily
take out a city
pretty easily take out a country
sometimes take out like the one that
took out the dinosaurs take out pretty
much every big living thing on the
planet that's happened before and it
will happen again
um now the Big Planet Killer so-called
Planet Killer asteroids are very rare
um I can't remember off top of my head
it's something like one every 100
million years or so roughly you'd
imagine but and we had one about 60 odd
million years ago right
um but the little ones that can take
cities out there was one in Siberia
in uh I think it's 1908 I might be
slightly wrong but roughly the first bit
of the 20th century that exploded in an
air burst over Siberia and flattened an
awful lot of forest and if that had
happened over a city it would have
flattened an awful lot of City so these
things happen what we do now is we look
for them quite sensibly so we met the
orbits of as the big asteroids we've got
most of them we think
um that cross the Earth orbits and we
monitor them all the time and we have a
what's called a keyhole system and it
says if one of these asteroids goes
through this point in space at this time
then we're worried about it and we'll be
very careful and we'll watch it so we're
watching them
um and everyone goes through the keyhole
then you what you need to do is nudge it
a bit so it doesn't hit the Earth and
the dark mission was the first mission
designed to make sure that if we really
want to hit an asteroid with something
then we can do it and it's hard and so
we did it it's a very clever Mission
because it's a double asteroid system
so um so what the little one that one of
them was hits there's two of them going
around each other then we hit one of
them and that means that you can measure
the orbit afterwards of these two things
orbiting around each other to see how
much we deflected it so it's a smart
thing to do so we're really developing
the technology so that if we have to hit
a big one and move it away then we can
do that and Carl Sagan he said correctly
the dinosaurs that had a space program
they'd still be around and that's that's
basically the dark Mission that's what
he's doing and there are bigger I mean
there are things we couldn't do anything
about comets are really problematic so
asteroid's a piece of rock they're in
orbit around the Sun and there's the
asteroid belt where there are lots of
them the Comets are more like often
described as icy snowballs and they come
from much further out a place called the
Kuiper belts or the Oort cloud so way
way out actually the old cloud of comets
extends probably about a quarter of the
way to the next star so you can go out a
light year as a this is all this stuff
around that we should basically icy
snowballs and they because of collisions
and interactions in the kaifabelle and
the Oort cloud or even passing Stars can
distrib disturb just anything can
disturb these things and they can come
and fall in towards the Sun and we saw
one recently Schumacher Levy nine
relatively recently which hit Jupiter
um and we we didn't see it coming until
a few months before it hit I think maybe
a year or something I think it was even
quicker than that maybe a few months
let's say and it it made a a bit of a
mark in Jupiter actually when it hit it
it was actually the the whole it left
was bigger than the earth right in the
clouds so these things they're big right
and they they come in and they're
unpredictable and we'd have a lot of
trouble with one of those so we'd have
less trouble with the asteroids at the
moment we'd have an awful lot of trouble
with the comments I don't there's
nothing we could do actually well we
will end on that note uh
but that shows you just shows you there
doesn't it we talked earlier about the
the how long it takes to get something
as complex as a human being on a planet
and you've got to avoid that and so we
did you know 65 million years ago or so
um the dinosaurs were pretty much wiped
out
and that left a little evolutionary
Niche for a little thing shrew-like
mammal type thing and and ultimately
that's why we're here if that hadn't hit
and wiped out cleared the way we
wouldn't be here you probably wouldn't
have a civilization you can guess and so
you know there would be none of the
things that we just take for granted in
the potentially the Milky Way galaxy so
if we're the only civilization in the
galaxy
then it's I think it's pretty likely
that if that Comet hadn't hit 65 million
years ago and white dinosaurs there
wouldn't be any civilizations in the
Galaxy so nobody nothing could know
anything
you know none of this knowledge would
exist so that just shows you how
precarious the position of civilization
and life is
as Yuri was bringing the spacecraft in
for the the first manual approach we
were just aware that things were not
going right we had another failure which
meant the computer screen went down so
Tim and I were effectively blind and
that was the point I realized this
approach is is just not good and Yuri
actually his hand started trembling on
the controllers